my point of view where it's worth is
that I don't think terrorism is very
important and I think we make it
important and by making it important we
make it important it does not matter
very much a terrorist incident is a
happening it's an accident it affects
the people directly in fact affected by
it and the terrorism does not threaten
States it doesn't threaten the integrity
of America or Britain that they caused
invaders they can't do serious damage to
our economy unless we let them they kind
of affect our values our democracy
anything like that unless we let them
they are they are to all intents and
purposes useless criminals they simply
blow things up and kill people that the
only point of which they threaten us is
by our reaction to them they have no
standing whatsoever other than in terms
of our reaction to them and our reaction
to them is conditioned by the publicity
we give them they depend upon publicity
the multiplier thought this is what
makes the terrorism act terrorism
otherwise it's just a killing that's why
very few terrorist incidents occurred in
autocratic and dictatorial countries
they didn't get any publicity now they
get obviously where we give them
publicity is on that publicity that they
feed